[Musique]
un Alberta la première ministre d'Agnès
Smith a finalement déposé son fameux
projet de loi sur la souveraineté
intitulée loi sur la souveraineté de
l'Alberta dans un Canada uni projet qui
a provoqué des remous partout au pays
cette semaine on va faire le point avec
mon collègue correspondant à edmunité de
Mathieu Goyer Mathieu on pensait qu'elle
allait peut-être adoucir le ton un peu
ça n'a pas été le cas très peu Daniel
finalement la première ministre de la
suite a déposé un projet de loi qui
avait beaucoup de mordant c'est vrai
elle aurait reculer sur sa promesse de
présenter un projet de loi quelle est
permet d'ignorer les jugements de la
Cour suprême qui ne plaisaient pas
l'Alberta là-dessus et leur culé mais
sinon sur le fond elle est allée avec un
projet de loi très agressif ce qu'elle
avait promis d'ailleurs aux militaire
conservateur rappelez-vous cet automne
durant la course à la direction du Parti
conservateur beaucoup d'éléments dans
cette pomme et les principaux vous les
connaissez déjà maintenant la liberté se
donne le pouvoir d'ignorer des lois
fédérales avec l'adoption simple d'une
motion
législatives d'Alberta se donne aussi le
pouvoir de forcer une entité provinciale
pensez ici à une ville ou encore à une
société de la couronne d'ignorer elle
également une loi fédérale mais ce que
provoquait le plus de réactions et de
remous je vous dirais que c'est une
autre disposition de la loi qui permet
encore là grâce à une simple motion
adoptée en chambre
une motion qui permettrait à l'Alberta
d'ignorer ou de modifier unilatéralement
une loi provinciale genre de pouvoir
extraordinaire qu'on s'accorde
uniquement en temps de crise ça crée
énormément de mécontentement un Teulet
face à cette olé Daniel Smith il dit
ouverte à des amendements à la Loi rien
pour calmer l'opposition et ça donner
des échanges assez cassés merci ici EDM
maintenant peu en écouter un extrait
[Musique]
sur sur le web hier dans un papier
d'analyse on espérait être menton que ça
morde du côté d'Ottawa c'est pas été le
cas non pas du tout vous l'avez entendu
comment Justin Trudeau ne veut pas
ajouter d'huile sur le feu même s'il n'a
pas exclu une éventuelle participation
du gouvernement fédéral dans la
contestation judiciaire qui pourrait
venir de cette loi ce que j'entends du
côté d'Ottawa c'est qu'on ne veut pas
faire de cadeau à Madame Smith faut pas
oublier qu'ici en Alberta on est à six
mois d'une élection on sait très bien
que Madame Smith elle aime autant
attaquer juste un Trudeau que la chef de
l'opposition on ne veut pas faire ce
cadeau là on ne veut pas donner de
munitions à Madame Smith dans cette
bataille qu'elle cherche à provoquer
avec le gouvernement fédéral c'est
pourquoi à Ottawa on garde une certaine
distance face à la loi sur la
souveraineté on veut aussi laisser aux
Albertins contestés la loi vous savez
ici il y a déjà suffisamment
d'opposition à la loi le gouvernement
fédéral ne sent pas la nécessité pour
l'instant du moins de se jeter dans la
reine et de rejeter également ce projet
de loi je le rappelle on est à 6 mois
des élections madame Smith a un travail
de vente à faire Daniel auprès des
Albertins parce que si le projet de loi
il plaît à la base conservatrice c'est
loin d'être acquis dans l'ensemble de la
population albertaine alors madame Smith
a une pente à remonter si il y avait des
élections demain matin en Alberta le NPD
aurait de bonnes chances de reprendre le
pouvoir si vous dire le défi qui attend
madame speed à quelques mois donc du
prochain scrutin ici en Alberta et là
effectivement du pain sur la planche
monsieur Goyer admettons merci
infiniment d'avoir été des nôtres bon
dimanche